I think it's important to have something
that's beneath the surface otherwise
you're writing essentially an elaborate
diary entry I think profundity is in the
eye of the beholder some of my some of
the essays I get that were eliminated
from the collection there were a couple
of them I decided not to include because
they didn't have enough and or any
universal application you know what was
me I got a parking ticket or you know
some boy was mean to me no one
particularly cares but you can make
people care about small significant
details and and sort of lend the entire
universe to a tiny detail you know
there's this sort of like famed Buddhist
meditation practice where you're
supposed to picture the entire world on
the head of a pin you know and I feel
like the only kind of meditation or
stillness or non neurosis that's ever
made any sense to me and that's sort of
what the essays try to do you know some
of the critiques have been that some of
them don't do that but some of them read
a little bit too casual I think when
you're writing personal essays it can be
difficult to suss out what seems
profound to you because they it's not
necessarily intellectually profound it's
sort of emotionally profound so if
you're just sort of coming through it
you know it's what speaks to you or or
what what does
it's funny I've spent i guess about
seven years in total encouraging my
authors not to pay too much attention to
the critics that all press is good press
you know book publicity is very
different than any other kind of
publicity and the fact that I friends
who work in music and film publicity and
it's much more defensive whereas ours is
much more you know please God mr. short
story writer go commit a felony so I can
get you some press it's very difficult
and so just to be written about and then
is a feat in itself and then I guess you
kind of worried about the tone second
and i think i have luckily taken a
little bit of that to heart the
criticism hasn't been too harsh or i
don't see it because their personal
essays i think if i let it all in
thoroughly it would be a critique of me
as a human being so it's very easy to
look at it and think you know a lot of
the book reviews have been assigned to
people who are slightly younger or my
age and you know i have been sort of
more interested to see the reviews by
reviewers who I know have been doing it
for a while and are really reviewing it
as a book as opposed to a extended diary
entry that they could have written if
only they had had a couple more Red
Bulls after work you know in it so it's
it's pretty easy to slough off but I
think it's important to let some of it
in and some of it's been really helpful
I didn't expect that I expected just to
be worried about getting press and
hopefully getting the book out there and
getting people aware of it and and some
of the critiques have been actually
really useful so that was a pleasant
surprise
you